Nessa's always on the lookout for
possible asteroid collision hazards
so the pan-starrs telescope is scanning
the sky every night
each morning candidate objects are
examined by pan-starrs staff and usually
discovered to be no big deal but on
October 19th 2017 penn star spotted an
object moving rapidly between the stars
and this time the usual follow-up
measurements of position and speed
showed something completely different by
october 22nd we had enough data to
realize that this object wasn't from our
solar system holy cow that's when I got
the phone call the phone call that all
solar system astronomers are waiting for
let me tell you how exciting this was
NASA's been expecting to see an
interstellar comet passed through the
solar system since the 1970s but until
now we'd never seen anything our own
solar system is huge so even getting a
package from the nearest star system 4.4
light-years away would take over 50,000
years so this is a really big deal the
interstellar visitor entered our solar
system from above the plain of the
planets coming from the direction of the
constellation Lyra and it passed closest
to the Sun on September 9th passing
inside the orbit of mercury now this
isn't a particularly close approach or
unusual distance it's just much easier
to see objects close by on October 14th
before we discovered it it made its
closest approach to the earth within
about 15 million miles this is really
close by astronomical standards now
rather than call this by its unwieldy
catalog name we briefly called it ramaa
after the cylindrical spacecraft that
passed through the solar system in the
arthur c clarke classic science fiction
story in 1973 but this wasn't quite
right either so in honor of it being
discovered by a telescope in Hawaii
we consulted two experts on Hawaiian
culture Hawaiian navigator and a
linguist to propose a name and they
suggested Oh mwah mwah which means scout
or messenger from the distant past
reaching out to us now this discovery
was important for many reasons but to me
the most significant is for what OMA
more can tell us about the past of our
solar system the process of the birth of
a new solar system and the growth of
planets can be a violent and messy
business left over icy and rocky debris
gets ejected from the new solar system
as the giant planets migrate through the
dusty disc out of which they're formed
now have you ever felt an emotional
chill something that's so exciting that
a shiver runs up and down your spine or
something that's very emotionally moving
well this was it for me this was my WoW
moment we actually had a piece of
material from another solar system
coming close enough for us to observe so
what would you like to know about Oh
mwah mwah
the very first visitor from another star
system well I could think of a million
things but there's what you want and
what you can have animal oil was moving
away and fading very rapidly in the span
of about a week it had dropped in
brightness by a factor of 100 so this is
about all the time we were going to have
to study it easily so we had to distill
the process of getting telescope time
normally a very competitive
peer-reviewed proposal process that can
take up to months down to less than a
few days so began a polite competition
for resources okay let me not mince
words it was a fierce battle we dropped
everything working around the clock
trying to craft perfectly crafted
proposal words to send to the
observatory directors well good news we
got the time
now from a perfectly selfish point of
view the first thing we might like to
know is how massive omoi is because
after all it passed very close to the
earth and we didn't know about it until
afterwards how bad would this have been
had it not missed the earth well the
impact energy depends on the square the
velocity times its mass and the mass
depends on how big it is and what it's
made of so how big is omoi and what's
its shape well we can get this from its
brightness now if you don't believe me
think of comparing the brightness of a
Firefly in your backyard to the airplane
lights navigation lights on a distant
airplane you know the airplane is much
brighter it just appears faint because
it's so far away we're also going to
need to know how reflective the surface
of omoi is and we don't have any clue
but it's reasonable to assume it's very
similar to small asteroids and comets in
our solar system or in technical terms
something between the reflectivity of
charcoal and wet sand nowadays most of
the big telescopes are used in what's
called a service mode meaning we have to
carefully develop all the instructions
and send them to the telescope operator
and then anxiously wait for the data to
come back praying to the weather gods I
bet most of you don't have careers that
critically depend on whether or not it's
cloudy last night well we weren't going
to get any second chances here because
the weather was great and Wilma decided
not to be its brightness wasn't constant
now here we see omoi racing between the
stars it's centered in the middle
the stars are trailed out because the
telescope is following its motion
it started faint and then it got
brighter fainter brighter and fainter
again as sunlight is reflected off of
four sides of an oblong object the
extreme brightness change led us to an
unbelievable conclusion about its shape
as shown in this artist's
oppression Oh Momo is apparently very
long and narrow with a nexus ratio of
about ten to one assuming it's dark
this means it's about half a mile long
nothing else in our solar system looks
like this we only have a handful of
objects that even have an axis ratio
bigger than five to one so we don't know
how this forms but it may be part of its
birth process in its home solar system
well oh mama was varying in brightness
every 7.3 four hours or so we thought as
more data started to come in from other
teams they were reporting different
numbers why is it the more we learn
about something the harder it gets to
interpret well it turns out that amumu
is not rotating in a simple way it's
wobbling like a top so while it is
rotating around its short axis it's also
rolling around the long axis and nodding
up and down this very energetic excited
motion is almost certainly the result of
it being violently tossed out of its
home solar system now how we interpret
the shape from its brightness depends
very critically on how it's spinning so
now we have to rethink what it may look
like and as shown in this beautiful
painting by space artist bill Hartmann
we think that oh mama may be more of a
flattened oval so let's get back to the
energetics what is it made of well
ideally we would love to have a piece of
a more more into the laboratory so we
could study it in detail but since even
private industry can't manage to launch
a spacecraft within a week to something
like this astronomers have to rely on
remote observations so astronomers will
look at how the light interacts with the
surface some colors may get absorbed
giving it a chemical fingerprint whereas
other colors may not on the other hand
sub substances may just reflect more
blue or red light efficiently in the
case of Oh mwah mwah it reflected more
red light making it look very much like
the organic rich
surface of the comet recently visited by
the Rosetta spacecraft but not
everything that looks reddish has the
same composition in fact minerals that
have tiny little bits of iron in the
surface can also look red as does the
dark side of Saturn's moon I a petition
in these images from the Cassini
spacecraft nickel iron meteorites in
other words metal can also look red so
while we don't know what's on the
surface we know even less about what's
on the inside however we do know that it
must at least be strong enough to not
fly apart as it rotates so it probably
has a density similar to that of rocky
asteroids perhaps even denser like metal
well at the very least I want to show
you one of the beautiful color images
that we got from one of the ground-based
telescopes alright I admit it's not all
that spectacular we just don't have the
resolution even Hubble Space Telescope
doesn't present a much better view but
the importance of the Hubble data was
not because of the images but because it
extended our observations out to
two-and-a-half months from the discovery
meaning we get more positions along the
orbit which will hopefully let us figure
out where omoi came from so what exactly
is o more more we firmly believe it's
likely to be a leftover archeological
remnant from the process of the birth of
another planetary system some celestial
driftwood some scientists think that
maybe omoi wa formed very close to a
star that was much denser than our own
and the stars tidal forces shredded
planetary material early in the solar
system's history still others suggest
that maybe this is something that formed
during the death throes of a star
perhaps during a supernova explosion as
planetary material got shredded whatever
it is we believe it's a natural object
but we can't actually prove that it's
not something artificial but color the
strange shape the tumbling motion
could all have other explanations now
while we don't believe this is alien
technology why not do the obvious
experiment and search for a radio signal
that's exactly what the breakthrough
listen project did but so far
omoi has remained completely quiet now
could we send a spacecraft to omo omo
and answer this question once and for
all yes we do actually have the
technology but it would be a long and
expensive voyage and we would get there
so far from the Sun that the final
approach trajectory would be very
difficult so I think amor amor probably
has many more things to teach us and in
fact there might be more surprises in
store as scientists such as myself
continue to work with the data more
importantly I think this visitor from
afar has really brought home the point
that our solar system isn't isolated
we're part of a much larger environment
and in fact we may even be surrounded by
interstellar visitors and not even know
it this unexpected gift has perhaps
raised more questions than it's provided
answers but we were the first to say
hello to a visitor from another solar
system thank you
thanks Karen I have and of course enjoy
that talk very much thank you as a
recall we found it pretty late in its
journey towards us
well future technologies like the large
synoptic survey telescope help us detect
these things sooner yeah we're hoping
that we'll start to see a lot of these
things and ideally you'd love to find
one as its approaching the Sun because
you want to have time to do all the
science or even more ideal you get a
spacecraft ready to go parked somewhere
in the l4 or l5 position somewhere near
Earth so that when something comes by
you can chase it awesome
thanks so much let's make carrot again
[Applause]